this is the Fox News Alert a cooches
County Arizona Deputy is really really
lucky to be alive tonight after being
really severely injured while chasing an
illegal alien according to sheriff Mark
Daniels one of his deputies was
deploying spikes during his Pursuit and
fell 15 feet okay well including rescue
efforts were involved and applied the
deputy was then flown by helicopter to a
Tucson trauma center the sheriff said
that this is the third time in the last
several days
where his deputies and citizens have
been placed In Harm's Way by Reckless
and violent criminal Smugglers due to a
border being neglected by those
entrusted in Washington DC to protect
Americans enough is enough when our next
guest is someone who knows a lot about
this he's the current Texas lieutenant
governor Dan Patrick Dan Texas lives
this story every single day and so many
of our border patrol agents have been
traumatized injured hurt and have even
lost their lives over the years because
of what they've gone through at the
border uh not to mention the people of
this country who've been injured and
brutalized as a result of some of these
criminal aliens Crossing in your
reaction tonight to this
story well our prayers for that uh
officer that Deputy in cooches county in
Arizona like our Troopers like our
sheriffs like our local law enforcement
and border patrol they're in danger
every day every day Laura I get a report
of some car chase some shots fired uh
some Trooper being at risk and here's
the reason Laura when you're smuggling
drugs or people across the border on
behalf of the cartel and you're that
coyote you're that guy if you go back
they're much more dangerous to face than
our law enforcement now sometimes they
get shot here sometimes they get killed
here but when they're coming across
their border they will do anything not
to go back if we confiscated their drugs
uh if we pulled over a group of uh you
know a car that has 10 12 people in it
or a truck with 30 people so the dangers
they face back there make them take risk
at here and that puts our officers every
one of them at Great risk every day they
go on duty Dan big news today when Elon
Musk uh actually traveled to Eagle Pass
Texas to see the chaos unfolding and I
watched some of it when he was live
streaming on X but there's one thing I
said I I heard him say that I would like
your reaction to watch we should uh let
anyone in the country who is hardworking
and honest and will be a contributor to
the United States uh we should have
expedited legal approval for anyone who
who sort of falls into that category
anyone who's honest and hardworking
should come into the country that's
about three billion people um what about
that I mean do we need to just open up
immigration make it much easier that's
what the Democrats say the systems
broken d but I mean that's a pretty
broad category of people and probably
about three billion
people yeah most of the world would like
to come to America you know we're the
only America that the only country that
people are you know coming to no one's
leaving America by the way do you see
many of Americans breaking into North
Korea or China or you know some Nation
around the world they all want to come
here for lots of reasons Laura and look
we need a a legal immigration system and
I BL blame both parties by the way the
Republicans and the Democrats both have
been in power with a president and a
Congress of that party whether it was a
Republican or Democrat president they
had their chance and Congress didn't go
along so I blame both parties for this
for different reasons and we could spend
20 minutes on that issue alone but we
need legal immigration and we should
only bring in the people that help
America be better um right now Laura we
try to bring in the best and brightest
in this country on various visas for
various jobs and we need to find people
that make our country better because
that's our opportunity do you take in
the poor and the needy in certain cases
absolutely but we cannot treat the whole
world's medical issues we can't educate
every child in the world uh we don't
have a place for everyone in America and
Laura this is uh this is so clear look
what's happening to our social safety
net in big blue cities it's collapsing
because of illegal immigration we cannot
take care of everyone in the world and
it's nothing wrong with bringing in the
best the brightest and those who need to
come here who are in Jeopardy in some
other country not like they're coming
today everyone claiming a Sol not all in
fact 90% of the time the judges send
them back when they make that claim yeah
we have about 20 million or plus 25
million illegal immigrants in the United
States right now all have their put 4
million long well whatever it we don't
even know so that's my problem 15% 15%
of our population by the time Biden's
out of office will be here illegally
that's because the MIT study in 2016
said 25 to 30 those match up with my
numbers I've studying it forever bu will
in 12 million or so since he's been
there you're close to 40 45 million 10
15% 12% of entire population but Dan
that's why this idea like we're going to
bring in everybody who well we we we
don't even know who's here we've got to
make sure we deal with the problem them
he's the richest man in the world he's
wor 240 billion you bring everyone here
Elon you'll be out of money soon yeah
well they they keep wages low for for
workers though wages stay really low
when you flood the market so Dan thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else